what a great idea
nice game with your dog
Oh
thank you
I'm eating pigeon so we're playing
tourist today my best friend in the
whole world Desiree is he so excited she
came in from Pittsburgh and her husband
is here as well and we're having so much
fun and there's down
we're just doing some touristy things so
come along as we play tourist you guys
have seen me do the same sort of tour
many many times before but we're here
it's great
we just had some some delicious food and
we are the fairest machine right there
as well okay all right it is
this is gonna come
see
arms
you
alright guy from girl throwing in on my
shirt and I weighed over to do this so I
tried something a little different make
it count
oh okay oh god I miss that rule car back
okay well that's it work out
that's the basketball basketball we've
got basketball
don't do this son
maybe they don't have one okay we're
gonna win
smarty I'll have Michelangelo please yes
thank you
Mattia love it
Wow
yeah
all right
just here in my new car
just getting one store and we're just
cruising here and going absolutely
nowhere and does she's like oh it's just
up let's just pull up a website here
whatever that great thumbnail hi baby
boy you look good
so I've got this dog so many different
types of cones because I want him to be
comfortable and I've had so many fails I
actually make a blog post about it so if
you guys are looking to get a perfect
cone for your dog I'll show you the ones
not to get but I got this one which
actually might work for him but it also
actually got a fits on my head
Jen can you help me with this hey like
this socks it's actually not that bad as
well it's a baby it's very malleable you
don't you think did you think I am I
mean you weren't a cone on your head oh
wait this is a coin good truffle oh no
this is X account yeah I thought that
was your travel ability Brian oh it's a
good something that you wear in life
there the pool just like a sense of
floating Maddie
I like you I like you I'm just liking
you ha ha ha better go get your mommy
get piggy puppet movie look at us look
at us
play play Wow
oh he's little happy so we had a very
fun touristy day yesterday in Santa
Monica now today we are gonna go do some
other fun things I don't know what's
gonna happen I never usually know but I
do know first we're going to the
Microsoft lounge and we're taking Mauro
me there are you ready to go to the
Microsoft Lounge gosh you're so purple
swag down
come on let's go ready oh it's just a
sad sight Maddy looking through the
Microsoft Lounge buddy do you love it do
you love it oh you're so handsome this
looks so great so here at the Microsoft
Lounge and they just redid it and it's
so I'm just kind of doing my living room
it's a big circular dining table this
over here is a massive one two three
four sixteen screams
and Maddie oh honey you can't fit
through the room with your comb
he just looks pathetic we
color-coordinated today so we're doing
some surface demos here and we've got
Jenna going over here riding around I'm
Sean chasing Maddie around guys I'm in
love with the surface book
it's so awesome look I'm selling
pictures if you guys let me to draw you
a picture I will draw one person one
photo leave me a comment of what you
want me to draw and make you a picture
can we talk about this burgers the
pretzel burger it is a pretzel bun and
apparently before the original place
where the pretzel bun was invented
peanuts a bold statement but it's true
all right no but I don't the Microsoft
service that I got at the lounge today
I'm so freakin pumped to try this out oh
I just opened it just as like now on I
opened the wrong way smells Electronics
my gosh this box smells like it I love
the new electronics so much delicious
I'm very jealous I live like Minecraft
on it what is it a laptop or is it it
disconnects ya laptop tablet you just
push this button and disconnects and it
basically like reduces the processing
power of the tablet so that it saves the
battery and then when you plug it back
in it does like the pool anytime as fax
does it have like oh it's got my 7 then
it's got 917 ha my gigs of ram I'm I'm
sure I mean I'm gonna say it then Li 16
look at his mouth this is incredible I
haven't put the batteries in yet but let
me show you just let me show you this
mouse is off mouse is on mouse is off on
muscles off mouse is on
it's on it's turning on here's the mouse
look on oh it's not it's connecting how
it said yes oh mama told me make
yourself some friends to me what's good
New Year soon hmm let's get a few things
out of the way okay both master sleepy
all right guys thanks so much for
watching tomorrow I'm having an early
birthday party so stay tuned for that
vlog it's gonna be wild and it's
extremely wild gonna be what a la la do
something instead of a me I need a drink
man I snack we use ordered ramen do you
do you not like soup that ramen tastes
fish it is really good okay bye guys see
you later tell Matt that he should like
ramen wallah okay
next up a lots of jalapenos put a little
those in there